oh wait I'm going to send you guys a
test and we're going to so there's this
new personality test that me sent me oh
my God all right let's do it but it's
actually pretty fun right cuz it's like
we we'll take a break cuz I do I do need
to go to the toilet um but the way they
do it it's kind of like Pokemon
types so so I love those unhinged V like
which Pokemon would you [__] so I I did
my test and for like a lot of it
obviously it's like a cold it was pretty
inaccurate but for like the types that
it told me that I would like get along
well with Mine mine's in Chinese you can
you can switch Yeah I didn't see that
part all right let's seebe I should do
it my you now oh my God this is already
so pretentious you are now embarking on
a journey to explore your innate
personality relax and take why does love
these I don't can understand people no I
don't think it do all right let me all
right let's let's do this uh test people
are so unreliable books I've met people
I'm going to say who who tell me their
personality type and I'm like that's
what you think you are that's not what
you are you're very different to your
image of yourself we all are because we
all view ourselves very differently to
how we actually are and we're terrible
at being honest with
ourselves also like perspective based as
well absolutely yeah I think you don't
need these quizzes because you can read
people oh okay so you can't like you
need to understand oh I didn't I didn't
understand it from that perspective I
guess that makes more sense yeah yeah
did you see that video about the the guy
he's he this new YouTube is kind of like
blown up he did this video about like 10
animals that love to get
high and I didn't know about this but
apparently Dolphins will like lightly
bite poisonous puffer fish and kick it
around to each other so they can all
have a bite and get high [__] yeah what
are we talking about
dolphins I know me I hang out with
Sydney and you two talk about that [__]
all the time apparently King lemur uh
black lemur sorry they just like find
poisonous like centipedes and just like
lightly chew on them and pass it around
to each other and get [__] stoned I
mean the biggest is just so funny the
biggest ston is in the animal kingdom
are koalas yeah also apparently uh birds
and bees they just sometimes they get
high on or drunk on like fermented
fruits or stuff as well I all right so
we just did this personality test that
Meen sent us um I'm a what what type
were you I'm water type I'm light type
I'm a Steel type
oh [__] apparently my least compatible
types are ground and water I you and I
are not
compatible appar apparently I'm most
compatible with light type so but this
is also [__] because my innate my
compatible me is [__] dude my innate
personality there's like a bunch of them
go big or go home it is what it is no
excuse I'm ready and I'm a 10 out of 10
that is not me that's not him that is
not me discing you believe in the the
Chinese zodiac symbols for you they they
mean anything to yourself Chinese zodiac
symbols yeah they're like different
zodiac symbol you're the horse that's a
[__] good year what are you
rat hey he won okay he won number one
baby we don't lose say less we win at
any cost I'm a dog that's a good boy
yeah good boy I'm a good boy well so op
because I have a cousin who's like year
the dragon and I'm like imagine being
Year of the Dragon that's next year
right I think I think it might be next
but like that's just like so
overpowering to every other animal on
what are you I'm a dragon [__] all right
all right all right the rat won the race
that's all that matters bro that's all
that matters sounds like copium to me oh
he won he won I don't know it's the best
you won you won the race and also start
of the plague so you got to have it up
and down yeah dragons are
extinct what did you guys Ying they
personality uh light yeah oh yeah what
what are the five things that yeah oh it
was okay [__] I closed it but it was
like I'm excited to do it I'm a bit
lonely I'm happy or something I was like
this all doesn't sound like me at
all what does your all say uh my innate
personal this this just makes me sound
like uh this just makes me sound like
botchy basically so uh in a personality
worried no news is good news Okay regret
he/ she knows me calm down and it's just
like a a water droplet with like sweat
drops that just sounds like a paranoid
schizophrenic like it's like oh God
what's going to
happen oh my goodness yeah so um thanks
me uh for giving us a [__]
personality
test but at least I know uh we aren't
compatible Jerry cuz you know that's wow
what a shame we have to we have to stop
talking to each other I I think we need
to stop trash taste because uh we water
super it's not easy being the glue that
holds it all together someone's got to
bring the boys together the the Nick
Fury of trash taste some call
me you have the same personality type as
Sydney apparently light yeah Sydney got
light as well dude I well half the
questions I didn't even like the answers
to we we'll link it the one that we used
yeah the the moment where the question
was like you encounter a talking bird uh
in the cave that starts like saying all
your option I was just like where was
the it option like what the [__] a bird
is talking to me kill it I'm hungry
actually I need to eat you know in in
real life you always have the the attack
prompt there but we just never do it
[Music]
true never it's actually fact never
worth it we always choose to run yeah we
always choose to run or use items or
Escape call a friend or so I I was
talking to Meen earlier this week cuz
mean's apparently like starting a farm
and some [__] and
she yeah you saw that yeah she's going
to get chickens and stuff wow yeah we're
just casually talking
about she going back to Stan Ro yeah so
my big question is okay you have an
animal on your farm that you know you're
going to kill one day for food yeah do
you name it yeah of course this isn't a
hypothetical this actually happened to
me oh this this actually happen my
grandma owned two chickens and uh we
named them they were pets and uh when
they two all toay eggs we killed them
and ate them you can you can love an
animal and I think that a part of the
process of life is just you know
ultimately if somebody has lived its
life and you eat it and it gives you it
furthers your life you know and I think
I think that I'm happy to know that
those chickens that like my grandma and
I and like our family cared for is part
of me now yeah you know I I you know I I
think that if you're going to take care
of a chicken and show out love you know
and then it gets too old you may as well
eat it you know I get Fujimoto ate is
goldfish dude
like
you of the C it's part of me now animals
eat animals all the time you know what I
mean I we're just a bit more
compassionate and weird about it that's
true ever since we had an abundance of
things you know especially when animal
fig it's a privilege we figured out like
[__] junk food and I think it all
went downhill and we were like how do we
make everything
[__] well here's the thing okay I don't
know if I've ever like brought this up
on trash tast cuz it feels like a topic
I've already brought up but I don't know
if it's something I've done in private
or not but like okay why is it that all
the food that like taste good are [__]
for your body why why why why why is
beers like [__] for your body it's just
you know God's why is McDonald's [__]
for your body when it's like the most
processed [__] but it tastes [__]
Godlike I mean CU we figured out what
the human body identifies as being tasty
generally and it just so happens that if
you put all of those things in one and
and prepare in a certain way it's
generally bad for you like the one thing
that I think people like burgers can be
kind of healthy for you if you cook them
in a certain way and prepare it in a
certain way it's just the way we cook
them and we add all this [__] to make it
bad yeah but why is it the fact that
like all of these like superfoods that
like people say like oh yeah it
increases your life expectancy it
improves everything healthwise most of
them just kind of taste like ass yeah
like like surely surely if like the
human body like if if evolution was a
thing surely would be evolved to make
the good tasting food also like the best
food as possible for our body as well we
like we need fat and other kinds of
things that we commonly now because we
don't need to we don't need fat as much
to survive as we used to yeah but you
needed fat and fat was the thing that
made things taste like great you know
butter you know yeah that kind of stuff
would make things taste amazing so I
think I I don't think it was negative
it's just in the Modern Age It's become
negative cuz we don't I don't need to
stay warm in winter I can just put a
code on made of some crazy chemical that
somehow keeps everything in and
everything out like you know we've we
are just living in a time where the age
to that all the rules have changed
drastically in 150 years so now suddenly
it becomes a lot harder and then we
figured out how to process [__] and add
weird chemicals to stuff that are
terrible for us we used to put [__]
Asbestos and stuff you could smoke
asbestos
cigarettes how many times are you going
to bring this up I just I just can't
believe that was a thing that we
did Jesus people in like 50 years being
like can you believe we smoke cigarettes
no no I mean people willingly made that
decision to do that yeah it's just you
know I think that people saying that now
there's nothing there's nothing like I
think also taste buds are a big factor
some things taste really good for some
people some they don't but generally
like fatty things and stuff coated in
butter or garlic tast yeah but I've
never seen anyone who's like oh yeah my
favorite food of all time is
kale I [__] love kale I've never I've
never met a single person who's like
yeah kale is my alltime favorite like if
I my last meal if I was on death row
would be a bowl of [__] kale you know
what [__] me up what found out that
they like bred brussel sprouts to taste
better in like the P like recently I
believe that like they taste so much
better now like all brussels sprouts I
think in America at least the Brussels
sprouts every single time I go to
America right I always order brussel
sprout
because for some reason they taste
insane in America when I was growing up
they were like the well you like them or
you don't but you know we'll see about
it and I I I really like them growing up
well the the meme was that kids wouldn't
eat the brussel sprouts [__] love
them growing up they taste so [__]
good I didn't like them growing I not
like I loved them growing it's only when
I became an adult where I'm like I can
appreciate the bit of fact track this by
the way I can appreciate the bit of
flavor of these brussels sprouts now
that I have a wider palette but when I
was a kid I was just like this [__]
nasty as [__] I LEL fedge I don't think
I should but I think I could if I have
butter available as well